Let me show a very simple example just to
remind you of a geometry
which is not the geometry of Euclid.
In which the proposition that every triangle
is 180 degrees simply does not hold.
And it's a familiar and an easy geometry which
we know all the time.
Imagine this balloon to be a sphere. I will
work on part of it only.
It will be rather spherical.
If I draw a small triangle.
I think you will believe that nearby, if I
look at it closely, it is very near a flat
surface,
and my propositions will not be much different,
if I work on the flat surface.
But if I draw a large triangle.
A line like that.
And let me draw a nice right angle here.
It's a good right angle.
And a nice right angle here,
that's a good right angle.
Then if I continue with straight lines, of
course on the flat plane
I never meet, but here I make a splendid triangle.
Well, I submit, if they're 90 degrees here
pretty close,
and 90 degrees here pretty close, I've used
up the 180,
there must be something to assign to that
triangle.
Of course you know very well the theorems
of Euclid
simply do not apply in the non-Euclidean geometry
of a sphere.
And what determines whether they apply or
not, how closely they are approximated,
is one thing, and one thing alone, namely,
is the triangle large or small?
And when I say large or small I say with respect
to what?
And of course the answer is quite clear, large
or small with respect to the sphere.
If they are tiny triangles as we draw triangles
compared to the great globe of the Earth,
then Euclidean geometry works.
If they are huge triangles, like the triangles
made on the sphere
by the lines of longitude and latitude, then
Euclidean geometry is no longer true.